alors pour continuer on va parler un peu
de vous en fait on va parler de jeunesse
j'ai le grand plaisir d'accueillir sur
scène celle qui est quelque part mon
homologue d'entre eux porte parole du
modem
secrétaire d'état à la jeunesse chars
sarah on t'a vu partout au début de
l'été à accompagner le déploiement du
service national universel
je crois que ces dix-huit jeunes qui ont
participé
et un grand merci pour ce que tu fais
dams et monsieur sahara est la grille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monsieur le premier ministre
c'est le comice en planches et françois
chez stan se le délégué général mes
chers collègues chers militants cher
engagé mais surtout cher jammes
quel plaisir très cher amboise kelp les
yeux quel plaisir de se trouver ici
aujourd'hui avignon se retrouver en
famille se retrouver réunis alors même
que tout le monde se divise alors que
tout le monde se chicane non ce n'est
pas notre cas nous sommes heureux
heureux d'être ensemble
je ne sais pas pour vous
mais c'est la rentrée la rentrée elle a
été tonitruante les annonces n'ont pas
manqué d'ailleurs depuis le 20 août
depuis le 20 août dernier
chaque dimanche nous avons un nouveau
candidat à l'élection présidentielle oui
c'est l'automne c'est la saison des
champignons et ça on pousse partout
et cette année mais mes chers amis ça
n'a pas manqué il y a plein de variétés
monsieur prémunissent trouver oui
beaucoup il ya les champignons vénéneux
cette année cela ils sont très connus
ils ne s'intéressent qu'à une chose
l'obstination des prénoms oui mes amis
il y a aussi les champignons
hallucinogènes cela il oppose la fin du
mois et la fin du monde un seul un seul
sujet un seul cap déconstruire et puis
il ya une variété un peu plus délicate
les champignons de paris alors c'est pas
très résistant une fois que lui
mes meilleures amies
ya encore des champignons empoisonné là
c'est le père qui préfèrent le cousin
germain à la fille mais ça ça les
concerne
je ne serais pas plus longues sur les
champignons mais c'est parce que nous
venons de tous les territoires parce que
nous sommes unis et parce que surtout la
saison est finie il nous reste pour
finir les champignons surgelés ou en
boîte c'est en choix certains ont trempé
beaucoup trop longtemps dans les boîtes
ils n'ont pas vu que ce qu'il propose
comme idée fraîche nous les avons fait
est déjà fait
avec ce sacré aux deux champignons moi
j'ai pas spécialement envie de goûter
sachant que les derniers c'est les
champignons surgelés ils savent pas
s'ils vont être mangés à la sauce
piquante du congrès ou à la sauce yaourt
la primaire mais encore une fois nous ça
nous fait pas rêver associé aux
champignons vous savez ils sont tous à
la recherche des recettes des recettes
magiques et des recettes magiques en
particulier pour la jeunesse mais pour
le parti socialiste le seul projet la
seule obsession c'est ce rs1 ce rsa
généralisé alors même que celle
assignation à résidence mes chers amis
ils ont oublié ils ont oublié le goût du
travail le goût de l'émancipation le
goût du mérite
mes chers amis
la recette
chez les républicains il y en a même
plus il n'ya même plus de démagogie
c'est plus rapide pas de propositions
pas de regard et font plus semblant mais
la recette magique chez les le pen et
cousins c'est à chaque phrase une
polémique à chaque phrase à chaque mot
une fracture ce n'est pas notre projet
se sont ils sont à la recherche de ces
roches est magique qui n'existe pas qui
n'existe ni pour notre jeunesse ni pour
notre pays oui mes amis elle n'existe
pas de baguette magique parce qu'il n'ya
pas une jeunesse dans nos pays mais des
jeunes s il ya des visages y sont à
votre image
et je peux vous le dire avec mes
collègues chacun avec le premier
ministre avec les parlementaires sur le
terrain avec plus de 100 déplacement
depuis la chance et depuis mon entrée au
gouvernement eh bien on les a vus ces
jeunes on les a regardés chacun comme
ils sont là où ils sont avec leurs
fêlures avec leurs forces et leurs
talents mais jamais vous savez il ya des
jeunesses d'emplois dans notre pays qui
galère bien sûr il ya des jeunesses qui
entreprennent il ya des jeunesses qui
étudiait cette jeunesse des milieux
ruraux parce qu'on ne vit pas de la même
manière quand on est à qu'à son camp et
à nantes on ne vide pas de la même
manière si on est déjà parent à 20 ans
ou si on ne l'est pas il ya cette
jeunesse ultramarines aussi belle que
riche l'innovante
on ne ment pas on ne ment pas en les
regards parce que c'est notre france
c'est celle qui a acquis par son essence
conjugue nos différences conjugue nos
diversités pour faire un commun parce
que c'est notre identité et à chacune
d'entre elles il y a un projet un chemin
parce que c'est notre projet mes amis
c'est plus de 3 millions de jeunes qui
ont été accompagnés par le plan de nos
solutions et ça c'est concret ce n'est
pas des mots ce n'est pas des slogans ce
sont des vies ce sont des parcours qui
ont trouvé le chemin du travail et moi
je vous le dit c'est jeunesse elles ont
un point commun elles ont cette flamme
cette flamme de l'engagement quelle
qu'elle soit lord quelles que soient
leurs difficultés quelles que soient
leurs familles quelle que soit leur
couleur de peau quelles que soient leurs
études oui cette flamme de mes
engagements elle existe il y un paradoxe
il y à un paradoxe il est réel on a
malgré cette jeunesse
engagée on a une jeunesse qu'ils croient
plus à l'action publique une jeunesse
qui bout de nos jours une jeunesse qui
oppose l'engagement est l'expression
démocratique à celle là nous avons une
réponse est oui avec les jammes avec
vous tous ici je crois que la seule et
unique réponse et de leur prouver oui
par la preuve que nos quatre ans nous
avons fait nous avons fait concrètement
nous n'avons pas arrêté et nous
continuerons à faire pour les chèques
prochaines années
très concrètement
très concrètement mes amis
la fin de la précarité menstruel le
congé paternité concrètement la pma pour
tout concrètement le 0 et reste à charge
concrètement la suppression de la taxe
d'habitation les maisons françaises
glisse partout 14 millions de repas
crous distribué à tous les étudiants
grâce à vous oui grâce aux propositions
déjà mme c'est aussi la loi de bien-être
animal cher julien s'est également les
petits déjeuners gratuits cher jean
michel la dissolution des associations
qui ne respectent pas nos pacte et
qu'ils mettent à mal notre république
oui c'est lutter aussi contre toutes les
discriminations
avec une plateforme nous regardons notre
pays et nous le changeons concrètement
aujourd'hui partout c'est aussi
évidemment le doublement de la garantie
jeunes sert elizabeth je pourrais
continuer monsieur promises pendant des
heures mais je sais que ce n'est pas le
jeu donc je vais m'arrêter là sur le
concrètement et je sais que chacun
d'entre vous voient et je crois que
c'est la preuve mais notre action nous
allons la poussée jusqu'au jusqu'à la
dernière minute jusqu'au dernier quart
d'heure parce que nous sommes s'est
engagée qui portons la justice sociale
parce que nous sommes s'est engagée qui
sommes pour la liberté la liberté
d'entreprendre ne travaille qui émancipe
parce qu'il fait grandir parce qu'il
libère nous sommes s'est engagé aux
côtés du président de la république ce
président qui est le président de tout
les jeunesses de france
vous savez
vous le savez les amis
je suis celle celle de ceux qui pensent
que la france est une chance que la
république est une chance au rêve
américain je préfère le rêve français le
rêve et opère européen très cher clément
aux obsessions ethniques je préfère le
choix de la citoyenneté parce qu'en
france on n'oppose pas parce que dans
notre pays on ne fera demande pas parce
que oui nous bâtissons cette communauté
nationale ce qui nous lie ce qui nous
transcende oui mes amis la communauté
nationale qui repose sur ces essentiels
parce qu'ils ne sont pas négociables ni
qualifiable niro définissable la liberté
c'est connaître et comprendre son
histoire avec tout ce qu'elle comporte
pour penser en citoyen libre l'égalité
c'est permettre à chacun de ces levées
de s'émanciper la fraternité bien sûr
c'est ce qui fait de nous un peuple le
peuple de france un peuple solidaire la
laïcité vous savez que ça me tient à
coeur c'est ce qui permet de faire un
tout en respectant chacun pour conclure
pour conclure nous le faisons et nous le
faisons concrètement parce que c'est
notre méthode parce que c'est ce que
nous sommes l'égalité la fraternité la
laïcité c'est la loi confortant les
principes de la république et le contrat
d'engagement républicain avec le premier
ministre nous n'avons rien lâché pas une
seconde c'est le service national
universel qui permet à nos jeunesse de
se rencontrer de se comprendre et de se
faire et de faire ce peuple de france
c'est cette réserve civique ou plus de
trois cent mille jeunes femmes jeunes
hommes se sont levés et sont venus
donner un coup de main pour notre pays
ce modèle français
ce modèle français seraient français le
moule en vie et nous l'avons entre les
mains alors protégeons le choix ion le
la seule façon de le faire vivre ce rêve
français c'est de faire l'unité la seule
façon de faire vivre ce rêve français
c'est de faire société la seule façon de
faire vivre et de partager ce rêve
français c'est de faire que chacun sa
place que chacun a sa chance vous savez
la seule façon de pérenniser ce rêve
français c'est de faire famille et c'est
ce que nous faisons aujourd'hui parce
que c'est notre projet
c'est celui d'une maison commune c'est
cher françois c'est celui d'une
coopérative et vous savez que je viens
de l'économie sociale et solidaire c'est
des endroits qui sont pas comme les
autres parce qu'on considère que chacun
sa place chacun peut apporter quelque
chose et parce que nous sommes tous des
pierre de cet édifice alors assemblant
les assemblant les tailles on les bat y
sont nous avons nous le vivons déjà et
c'est pour ça que comme bâtisseur je
vais inviter quelqu'un de particulier à
me rejoindre vous connaissez son visage
vous connais son engagement vous
connaissez vous connaissez son énergie
indéfectible évidemment ambroise
c'est à toi c'est avec toi c'est le
président des jeunes avec mâcon
[Applaudissements]